hello everybody um I'm Maurice Samuels
and I want to welcome you I'm the
director of the Yale program for the
study of anti-Semitism and uh I want to
welcome you here today um before we get
started I just want to um advertise our
talk for next week um where I'll be in
conversation with Ken Stern about
anti-Semitism after October 7th um so
we'll be trying to address the current
um situation um today though we're going
to go backwards in time to maybe
somewhat um easier time although maybe
not um but with a real expert um who's
also an old friend uh Brian chayet he's
uh Professor am Meritus of modern
literature and culture at the University
of reading and a research fellow at the
University of Southampton Brian has
published or edited an astonishing 11
books uh four of his early Publications
were on anti-Semitism as a form of what
he calls Semitic discourse these include
constructions of the Jew in English
literature and Society from
1995 and between race and culture from
1996 his recent work connects the
history of anti-Semitism with
colonialism and anti-black racism in um
for example diasporas of the Mind
published by Yale University press in
2014 and ghetto a very short
introduction published by Oxford
University press in 2020 he's currently
writing a comparative history of
testimony from slave narratives to
Refugee Stories the talk that he'll give
uh today is called Edwardian popular
culture and everyday anti-Semitism and
is part of an unpublished article
article on the long history of social
media and
anti-Semitism uh so before I hand it
over to Brian just a word about how
things will work today um you we've
disabled the chat function but you can
ask questions using the Q&A function at
the bottom of your screen and then after
Brian finishes I will filter those
questions to him so um he plans to talk
for about 40 minutes and then we'll have
20 minutes uh for discussion so please
submit your questions in using the Q&A
function and you can submit them at any
time including during the talk um so
without further Ado I will hand it over
to
Brian thank you so so much Mari for that
uh very generous and kind introduction
and it's great to be in touch again the
last time I spoke at Yale I think I flew
in had a car gave my talk and flew out a
day or two later so this is much uh much
Greener much Greener and thanks so much
Anessa for organizing this seminar and
I'm going to now screen share and show
to show you all Ina's absolutely
fantastic
poster okay so you can see uh the poster
here which I'll come back to uh the
spider cat the spider cat also just to
say that um this is a part of a a work
that um speaks to the long history of uh
anti-Semitism on
um on uh a new media so I can actually
speak about the present day as well um
in terms of my lecture but let's first
of all let's start with the history and
then we'll see where we end
up so the age of trust triumphant you
can see um even though this is but uh a
phrase a wonderful phrase that a Henry
james' narrator uses in an
1894 story uh the ne the next time uh he
thought of the present day as the age of
trash
triumphant uh that is his present day
not ours but of course it could also
apply to ours and as we'll see though
1894 when the story was was written is
significant as it was the year when the
expensive three volume novel and you can
see an example here of a three volume
novel uh wilky Collins's uh novel we can
see
um um oh I must not touch I keep
touching there there it is H in three
volumes now the three volume novel H was
incredibly expensive only libraries and
the very wealthy could afford this and
it came to an end uh in 1894
uh um when um affordable one volume
paperbacks or yellow backs or Penny
dreadfuls were widely produced this
enabled bestselling novelist and we're
looking at four prominent examples uh
today including James's close friend
George de marier Who as a group ended
the library edition of the novel which
prevented authors from profiting uh
fully from the
work all of the authors that we're
looking at gained a mass readership of
many millions and all had multiple films
and Theatrical Productions based on
their work and all kinds of other
spin-offs as well um their
representations of Jews varied from as
we'll see anti-Semitism to philosemitism
and all points in between uh what I call
a Semitic discourse the novel was in the
early years of the 20th Century the most
accessible art form and sold in even
larger numbers in America where they
were even more uh cheaply produced and
you will see that this is a
transatlantic story um and I kind of
regret regret having Edwardian in the
title because really what we're talking
about is the end of the N 19th beginning
of the 20th century but in in both
Britain and
America the growth of best-selling
fiction not only changed the publishing
industry in the modes of book
distribution marketing and authorial
Entrepreneurship but culture itself for
the first time the novel was portable
easily accessible serialized in
sensationalist newspapers as I've said
and promoted by literary agents and
Commercial Publishers all new the
newspapers were new the Publishers were
new the literary agents were new as
well now my focus will be on the
mainstreaming as we Now call it of race
thinking about Jews and most other
minorities in this popular literature is
the medium the message did this new form
of cultural production enable extreme
illiberalism in the form of exclusionary
anti-Semitism to reach a mass
readership and yet I'll also ask if this
is just about the popularization of race
thinking or is religious discourse and
wider social conventions also part of to
mix these are the kinds of questions
which I'll attempt to answer so we can
see the four authors here that we're
looking at George de marier Hall Kane
Mari Carelli and Guy Thorne I suspect
George de marier Sven garley will be the
one that is best known to
you okay context everyday
anti-Semitism we'll see that
anti-Semitism has a variety of sources
in the popular no novels which certainly
includes race thinking and the rise of
political anti-Semitism in the 1870s but
he's often framed in religious terms as
we'll see and refers to the debates
concerning Jewish immigration from
Eastern Europe now the point I'm making
here is that the linear history of
anti-Semitism which moves historically
from religion to Nation to race does not
apply here each discourse exists
simultaneously and religion politics and
race were f Realms of disputes
concerning the value or not of Jewish
citizens and Jewish
refugees before the first world war
genre race thinking in the novel was in
a state of
flux but as Lisa Moore Lisa Moses left
argues now this is on the slide you can
see the second quote down there's a
paradox here liberal discourses were
part of the liberal public sphere and
this certainly applies to the novels we
we'll be
exploring so I think she makes a really
important book point in a book uh called
Jews liberalism and
anti-Semitism uh that that
anti-Semitism emerged political
anti-Semitism emerged in the LI liberal
public
sphere popular fiction was a mass
cultural phenomena which transformed the
educated reading public into book buyers
as I put here um as um as opposed to
book borrowers which they were before
the
1890s but bestselling authors didn't
speak with one
voice new
journalism uh certainly included um what
I've called egregious race thinking in
the context also they M mainstream this
in relation to society and culture it
depends whether they were left liberal
or or or not whether they spoke in one
voice but novelist certainly
didn't even the most egregious and
conspiratorial race thinking divided
Jews into those who would make desirable
and undesirable citizens and this was a
phrase used in in newspapers a lot
whether Jews were deemed rich or poor
acculturated or religiously visible
politically left or right the point
are they a good thing or not the novels
will explore are sometimes quite liberal
in their Outlook sometimes grously
illiberal and mainly a mixture of both
but they were part of the public sphere
as left argues we can see this when it
comes to what I call the B banalization
and this is the final quote of Christian
culture during this period Catholics and
Protestants were in feier sometimes
violent
disputes including anti Catholic acts of
parliament to Outlaw the Catholic
presence in the established
church Jews following historical
president were abused by Catholics or
Protestants in so far as they were said
to resemble their religious
opponent within Christian theology Jews
were after all thought of traditionally
as devil figures Christ Killers as well
as through their
conversion potential redeemers of Christ
and these uh discourses I think
especially in America uh will be quite
familiar these ambivalent beliefs at the
heart of Semitic discourse were
particularly potent in the popular
literature which we'll now explore
starting with Trilby by the angl French
author and illustrator George
dearia now we can see just one of six
films on the left here
um called sengar sometimes they were
called sengar sometimes they were called
Trilby uh this one Stars Mariam merch
and John
Barrymore um as prosthetic noses or je
Face seems to be uh um very much uh uh
in our thoughts among many other things
um we can see John barimore with his
prosthetic
nose now Trilby was published in a one
volume Edition in 1894 after the lending
libraries simply could not cope with the
demand for the novel it eventually sold
2 million copies in Europe and America
and inaugurated what has been called the
age of the bestseller after 200,000
copies were sold in its first six
months as can be seen on the on the
slide Trilby Mania as it was called took
a myriad of forms and gripped America
initially and here are as it's a fairly
long quote and my son is forever telling
me not to put long quotes on slides but
I'll read it according to one estimat
there were 24 dramatic Productions of
the novel playing at the same time one
town in Florida had a fenar square and
I'm curious to see if it's still there
and a little Billy Lake that was named
after tril's doomed
admirer there were countless Trilby
parties concerts based on the music in
the novel along with soap
toothpaste and that's literal soaps not
soap operas toothpaste shoes sweets
sausages hams Hearth brushes and the
everpresent felt hat which is still of
course the trby hat part of our
vocabulary the growth of popular novels
after Trilby was characterized by
literary Manas up until the first world
war but this did not significantly
result in a moral Panic about the nature
of Mass Appeal until after the
1920s but the other side of moral
certainty as Jonathan fredman has
contended in know uh in his uh wonderful
book The Temple of
culture
um as the other side of moral certainty
is the exclusion of those who do not
belong rivaling Trilby Trilby Mania the
love of the poor female
victim uh and we can see here
Sven garley I think uh John Barrymore
trying to
hypnotize uh um Trilby and trby
resisting his hypnotism in that poster
or that or that film still but the
opposite of trby Mia is sengali phobia
sengali phobia and one reason for the
novel's popularity was precisely such
easily digested binaries culture in the
form of music and beauty versus racial
exclusion here we can see the wonderful
image and I'm pretty sure it's um George
dearia was an illustrator so it's by uh
George dearia and we can see uh this
this image of the uh um spider cats the
weirdly ungainly spider
cat uh and I think though um before
looking a bit more at the spider cat uh
clearly a franchise waiting to happen uh
we need to distinguish between the text
reception and the narrative complexity
of even best-selling novels the figure
of sangi is extraordinarily ambivalent
he's both a dazzling musical genius and
a sexually repaci racial interloper and
his description removes him from any
known reality in other words Semitic
discourse works on the unconscious level
of fantasy as we can see uh by the quote
on the right hand side of the screen as
well as the supposedly more rational
race science which uh we'll look at in
the uh um second quote but first the
fantasmagoria the fantasy surrounding
fake garley it's as if he were a weirdly
ungainly cat and most unclean of course
the idea the dirty Jew and uh Mari Kelli
will see uses this awful phrase quite a
lot a sticky haunting long lean uncanny
black spider cat if there is such an
animal outside a bad dream this is very
much on the level of dream the
unconscious
Fantasy by mesmerizing Trilby known as
the apotheosis of voice and virtu
virtuosity sangy can IM Rapture his
audience to the point of H in the
novel's words Madness Spang garley
through hypnosis makes F makes tril's
voice again quoting
irresistible it forces itself on you no
words no pictures could ever do the
like both the audience and Trilby are
under sengar's
control trby menu in other words is both
a feature of the novel and antip IP Ates
its
reception the lit Mania surrounding
trulby may have been clearcut but
so-call Jewish racial difference is both
rejected and universalized by De marier
as we can see at the start of the book
concerning sengar's British rival for
the love of Trilby Little Billy and
here's the main quote on the screen
which I'll Now
read and this is a quote as I say from
the right at the beginning of the novel
and in little Billy's winning and
handsome face there was just a faint
suggestion of some possibly very remote
Jewish ancestor just a tinge of that
strong sturdy irrepressible indomitable
indelible blood which is not meant to be
taken pure fortunately for the world and
especially for ourselves most of us have
in our veins at least a minimum of that
precious fluid whether we know it or
show it or
not now the
transgressive
ambiguities concerning the preciousness
of sali's Jewish blood are immensely
troubling I think everyone has some of
this Semitic blood according to the
narrator in their veins but not too much
the novel for all its concerns about the
virtue of Trilby is on the side of
impurity
as indelible blood is not meant to be
taken pure and yet the all important
boundary between racial and sexual
Purity and impurity is impossible to
locate what could at least a minimum of
sank car's blood possibly mean trulby is
the product of fal's pure-blooded sexual
voraciousness and artistic virtuosity
and is shaped by these Unleashed
desires as seen in the novel stupendous
reception such desires are notoriously
difficult to control and could both
denigrate sengar as well as idolize TR
be okay our next novel and here we're
going to look at one spectrum of the
Semitic discourse the phos Semitic
Spectrum TR be Unleashed a veritable
slew of contradictory and free floating
free floating Jewish representations
which soon transforms fali from the
exception or the exceptional figure to
the
rule for the rest of my talk um um uh
and I'm assuming I've got time and I
want to focus on three best-selling
authors who unlike de marier combin
ComEd race and culture with
Christianity and as I say religious
discourse is just as important as uh
political and National discourses in um
at the time and in the text that I'm
reading now I'm going to start with as
I've said the philosemitic HC or at
least he was regarded as such by the
chief Rabbi Israel Zell and the Jewish
maban Club this was a club of
professionals uh intellectuals artists
who made Cain their one and only
non-jewish honory
member and Kane spoke at the club and
I'll I'll talk about one of his lectures
in a minute gain's novels sold more than
anyone
else's with lifetime s sales of about 10
million his Declaration of prophetic
wisdom fed into the fiction which laid
claim to spiritual quasi Christian
humanism and we can see an example of
this in the first quote on the uh slide
uh we can also see the extent uh with
the caricature here of of Cain the
extent to which writers became
celebrities their name as they are today
with celebrity authors above the title
and we can see on the right hand uh
image here the way that uh novels were
marketed uh very cleverly and
subtly so kan's f ISM the first quote
Palestine is a Jewish Commonwealth
protected by all the powers and perhaps
also partly controlled by them and if
this is not uh and if this is not the
Millennium the Jewish people have looked
for and prayed for it may be a step in
that General progress of the world which
is binding all parts and all peoples
together and you can see here how he
moves from religion religious ways of
thinking Millennium to humanism binding
All Peoples
together many of his novels plot lines
were based on the Bible and he was one
of numerous authors at the time who
wrote A Life of Christ I'm not sure
there's an ath a book on uh the numbers
of uh books on the Life of Christ at the
time well I think that would be an
interesting topic he was a firm
supporter of Zionism as we can see from
this quote and also zang's Jewish
territorialism and visited Jews in the
pale of
settlement on behalf of Anglo joran
wrote up his experiences in the London
times and a series of Articles he
distinguish between those who traveled
legitimately to the west and Those whom
he called euphemistically illegitimate
refugees sound familiar or quote
independent
immigrants that even V seats
distinguished between desirable and un
undesirable Jews can be seen in the
second quote which contended on the
slide which contended that Jewish
persecution was partly in response to
Jewish self-separation or
ghettoization so this is the uh shorter
quote on the slide may I dare to say
that it would be well if Jews came
oftener into the light and free error of
the world that is common to all men here
he was reflecting contemporary accounts
of anti-Semitism which BL Jews and
Judaism for their
persecution now one reason that Cain was
so successful is that he encouraged a
view of his work that Associated ethical
thinking with novel writing by placing
his self-proclaimed prophetic
imagination at the heart of his fiction
Cain replaced the uncertainties
concerning the established church
articulated in the so-called great
church crisis of the time with a higher
form of imagined
righteousness his Christian humanism
meant that when it came to the treatment
of persecuted Jews he became a firm
public opponent of anti-immigration
legislation on the grounds that it went
against the liberal principles which
made Britain as he put it rich and
free
now this quote shows uh the extent to
which um Hall
Kane um was well aware of literary
Jewish stereotypes and I think the
sophistication of this quote and this is
the lecture that he gave at the maban
club um where he talks about the
numerous and popular grotesque Jews such
as Fagan and dickens's Oliver Twist and
Zario fali these are all quotes from him
in contrast he welcomed what he called a
small group of noble Jewish studies so
he divided uh novels up uh crudely into
good Jews and bad Jews uh and the group
of noble Jewish studies which reflected
the Sublimity of the Hebrew Bible
through the lens of Scott ivanho
Benjamin's israeli's fiction George
Elliot's Dan Daniel D donda and it was
in this F MIT tradition that he wanted
to write in and wrote a novel called the
scapegoats 1891 which was to follow
these earlier precedents and add as he
put it to the noble Studies by
portraying a cultured heroic Jew a
cultured heroic
Jew and in this novel um
uh he compared his Cosmopolitan heroic
Jew with more ghetto Jews Jews who
rejected him and also showed the process
by which is his uh the hero in the
scapegoat eventually became heroic uh
and that very much included him becoming
a father to a daughter who he initially
rejected and of course fathers and
daughters go all the way back to
and his daughter
okay and I want to compare um hul's
philosemitism with Mari carelli's
anti-Semitism Mari Kelli also Associated
uh ethical thinking with her novels but
she took entirely the opposite
perspective of our arch rival hallc and
actively opposed the immigrants of Jews
into Britain and was one of the most
prominent supporters of the 45,000
strong British Brothers League who
campaigned for anti-immigrant
legislation the first such Act of its
kind which was eventually passed in
1905 a favorite of Queen Victoria and
Winston Churchills Carelli was the most
popular woman writer of her age who most
notably as I say rejected liberal
varities in the name of her bespoke
Christian values her Fame at its height
resulted in her best known novels she
published 30 in all selling more than
100,000 copies annually with overall
sale sales close to the 10 million of H
Kain whereas C was on the side of
tolerant British liberal conventions are
seen in his opposition to anti-immigrant
legislation Corelli his anti antithesis
was distinctly illiberal when it came to
what she called the spirit of the Jew
and she called uh talked about the
spirit of the Jew in an essay which I'll
Now read a chunk of called society and
Sunday the phrase the spirit of the Jew
uh I think um was very much in the air
at the time uh in terms of Otto vinger
uh the translation of sex and character
which was a another popular text which
talked about the spirit of the age uh
being uh meaning that m it is
Jewish and uh there's been a lot of work
on vinger I think the point that I want
to make and I haven't had time to make
it in in this talk is that there's all
kinds of connections and I'll make uh a
few later on I've already talked about
James and deoria there's a lot more to
be said about that uh we'll look at TS
Elliott uh um I'm haven't time to look
at Joyce or Virginia wolf or Dorothy
Richardson or junor Barnes but the links
between high and low culture the popular
and the literary are is very much uh a
subject that needs exploring but here we
just have uh the gutter Mary Carelli and
I'll read now from society and Sunday
according to the latest views publicly
expressed by both Christians and
unchristian clerics it would appear that
20th century Society is not one with
Sunday it no longer keeps the seventh
day holy it reads its upto-date
books and magazines and says the Sabbath
is a Jewish institution and though the
spirit of the Jew
pervades my whole
Constitution and composition and here
she's speaking in the voice of the
unchristian priests and though I borrow
money of the Jew whenever I find it
convenient there's no reason why I
should follow the Jew's religious
ritual so we can tell her Association
here between modernity and Jews and uh
uh very and she takes very much an
anti-modern stance in the name of her
bespoke
Christianity a letter of support was
read out at the rallies of the British
Brothers league and called for branches
of the BBL to counter what she called
the constant foreign invasion of our
land and our trade interests although
the leaders of the BBL which included
members of parliament for the East End
of London deliberately spoke of alien
rather than Jewish immigr immigrants to
avoid charges by the Liberal Party of
anti-Semitism this was not the case in
practice where cries of no more Jews
sweater and go back to Jerusalem were
common place at their Ries Jews were
also described in East End newspapers
written by BBL supporters as quote a
plague or exacting blood money or
crucifying east London and is generally
more demonic than human fancy using
Christian blood for their rich
was one uh um uh not very fancy B fancy
in the East End
newspapers now Kelli was quite at home
with such language in her 1894 novel
called barabus a rewriting of the
gospels and quite often uh she wrote as
if it was another form of the King James
Bible she evoked the blood liel when her
character barabus describes the
crucifixion as quote quot a great feast
of Slaughter the AP apotheosis of the
Jews this man of Nazareth was slain to
satisfy the bloodthirstiness
bloodthirstiness of the Gods elected
children of Israel the unresolved nature
of Jewish blood in De Mario's Trilby
published in the same year is here
settled
decisively now Kelli's anti-semitic
perspective uh placing very much over
culture and whereas I think uh my the
distinction I make is whereas Kelli plac
his race over culture Cain places
culture over
race now her perspective I think is
expressed most exctly in a
1999 title story called the song of
Miriam Which con concertin is together
an astonishing large number of literary
portrayals of Jewish Women following the
all-encompassing style of dearia B B in
the slums of Paris the story concerns
the murder of the elderly and
poverty-stricken Ruben David who lives
with Miriam his 14-year-old
granddaughter and is killed by his
predatory na na nephew Joseph Paris
Miriam becomes a famous Parisian opera
singer known as the Divine Mir armi Who
quote looked like a goddess and sang
like an angel her ravishing Grace had
won her the admiration of kings and
Emperors with told such preeminence on
the perisian stage makes her a cross
between Rachel Felix and Sarah burnhard
as well as curing up the decadent Paris
in
Trilby but unlike Felix and bernhards
Miriam stabs Ruben David in front of our
audience with the knife that was used to
kill her cherished grandfather she
justifies her actions by contending
brazenly uh that he deserved his fate it
is a just Vengeance she says here race
and religion is once again
indistinguishable as we can see from
some more quotes from the story and here
I'll read from the slide and we can see
uh an image of one of uh Mari carelli's
melodramatic and you can hear from her
style incredibly melodramatic stories
turned into films turned into theater
here the new woman who also was very
much castigated by Mari Carelli is is uh
going towards the devil the Satan figure
in the novel and you have a man pulling
her back in that front cover but let's
read the quote from the story uh to get
a bit more of corellian
melodrama a flash of large bright eager
eyes a glimmer of red lips and white
teeth and the tip of a decidedly Jewish
nose was all that could be discerned of
the 14-year-old Miriam
Joseph Perez could hardly and this is
when there he finds himself on the stage
with Miriam when they're both successful
opera singers Joseph peris could hardly
enunciate either words or music so
appalled was he at the terrible look of
Miriam's eyes it's always the eyes for
he saw his own dagger used to kill Ruben
David glittering in her hand and what
was far worse he saw
vengeance and of course uh well
Vengeance we can come back
to summed up where we move very much
from race to religion those who follow
the Mosaic law are not bound to love or
forgive their enemies and the god of the
Old Testament is not the god of the
new okay guy Thorn our last and final no
novel novelist H here I just want to
look at Jewish conspiracies in their
nent form before uh the protocols of the
Elders of Zion and the and there were
all kinds of conspir conspiracies to do
with uh Financial scandals at the time
but uh they were more complicated I
think it's a great mistake to read back
from the protocols after the Russian
Revolution and the first world war so
Geor now Kelli's Shameless race thinking
encouraged a slew of outrageously
illiberal popular writers in the first
two decades of the 20th century and I'm
looking at the best known of these
popular writers there are many many more
that are hardly known about uh hardly
known at all I've got a few of them I'm
just looking at my uh at my floor
covering yes here's one but no one has
written a word about t Kingston Clark T
Kingston Clark men versus Devils I bet
you can guess who are the men and who
are the
Devils lots and lots of these such
popular fiction I'm looking at the four
best known bestelling most influential
of
them the rest are largely
forgotten all of these popular novels
were to employ a heavy mix of IM
immovable racial and Theological
distinctions when it came to the figure
of the
Jew but it would be wrong to assume that
they were all writing from the same
perspective certainly at this in this
period guy Thorne for instance was a
professing Anglo Catholic whose best
known work of fiction when it was dark
the great conspiracy is its subtitle was
described by Freud and we can see this
from the short quote under underneath
the the book cover on your screen was
described by Freud as an English novel
of Catholic origin and the reason that
Freud uh um referred to the novel was
because he was looking at group
psychology writing about group
psychology and was writing about the
Catholic church and uh uh as we'll see
when it was dark was absolutely
everywhere in
1903 when Freud was doing his
research most bestsellers at the time
and this is the point were militantly
Protestants militantly anti-catholic and
this was part of the campaign to remove
Catholicism from the established church
at the time the great church crisis so
guy Thor was WR writing very much
against Against the Grain but Thorn's
Pro Catholic fiction caught the mood of
the time by denouncing what he called
and this is a quote uh from him he was a
journalist uh in his journalism he
talked about the curse of
indifferentism uh or what we would call
today secularism when it was as opposed
to the Supreme moral and spiritual
principles he championed and he
certainly championed them in his novel
when it was dark salt half million
copies and was the most read novel I
think in Britain I'm not sure that it
traveled in the way that uh some of the
other novels uh traveled to uh America
because this novel was very much part of
the great church crisis in Edwardian
Britain the great conspiracy and here we
come to the great conspiracy is an
attempt to prove that Jesus's
resurrection was a hoax by faking
archaeological
um evidence to show that the body of
Christ was removed from its tomb by
Joseph of
ARA so the the resurrection was a hoax
the no novel's devilish antihero
Constantine Schwab and I thought a lot
about his name Constantine obviously
goes back to the Roman Emperor but
whether the Roman Emperor was
anti-christian or not I think is open to
debate Schwab as as uh German uh
language uh speakers will know is a
robe how that signifies I'm not quite
sure maybe referring to uh the coats
that Ultra Orthodox Jews know we not
really sure but Constantine Schwab is
behind this conspiracy and blackmails
the keeper of biblical Antiquities at
the British museum to forge the ancient
records and place them in the holy land
so that they can be
discovered now no wonder the bishop of
London in in Westminster Abby and this
is the quote that I'll read in a minute
and many of the popular preachers
sermonized on the novel which was
anticipated in the novel's plot and now
this is a a familiar technique to
generate a particular response so the
response of the novel as with with TR
trulby and as with so many Hollywood
films that we watch is very much part of
the plot
of the uh popular movie or popular
novel uh so there's lots of sermonizing
in the novel and lots of sermonizes once
sermonizing once the novel's published
and the most famous sermon which Freud
refers to is by the bishop of London in
Westminster Abbey I wonder whether any
of you have read that remarkable work of
fiction entitled when it was dark it
Paints in wonderful colors what it seems
to me the world would be what the world
would be if for 6 months as in the story
is supposed to be the case owing to a
gigantic fraud the resurrection might be
supposed never to have occurred and you
feel the darkness creep around the world
when you and I won't go into details
here but Anarchy breaks out uh uh lots
of women are abused it's a a real
dystopia that the novel paints a horror
show when you see how Darkness settles
down upon the human spirits regarding
the Christian record as a fable then you
quit with something like adequate
Thanksgiving and thank God it is light
because of the awful darkness when it
was
dark now when it was dark has been
misread I think and this is why I talk
about Semitic discourse and we can talk
about this in the qu in the questions as
opposed to Simply anti-Semitism or Jee
hatred um or even philosemitism we can
see that uh uh in fiction at least
um in fiction at least uh um these are
quite um ambivalent ambiguous images of
Jews even in popular fiction so it's
been misread as being straightforwardly
a form of Jew hatred uh
um um and it's a complicated uh word
work uh unlike the other fiction perhaps
with the notable exception of Mari
Carelli even guy Thorn's nent Jewish
conspiracy theories were
bated so even though we have Jewish
conspiracy theories they were bipoc and
made up of good and bad Jews it was only
after the first world war and the
Russian Revolution that Jewish
conspiracy theories were hardened into
straightforward Jew hatred now my point
is that much of what I'm discussing is
ambivalent forms of race thinking which
I believe is akin to Binary forms of
gender stereotyping and I'm I'm more
than happy to expand this point in the
question and answer session as we can
see from the binary Jewish conspirators
in the novel and here um I think this is
the penultimate slide uh that I'll be
looking at so I'm hoping I'm okay for
time so first of all we're going to look
at Constantine Schwab the the um whose
hair was a very dark red smooth smooth
in abundance his features were citic but
without a trace of that fullness and
sometimes coarseness which often marks
the Jew who has come to the middle
period of Life the eyes we come back to
the eyes were large and black but
without animation they were coldly
terribly aware with something of the
Sinister and untroubled regard one sees
in a reptiles
eyes GB is a man of enormous power and
influence we're told who owns the
equivalent of the Times newspaper had a
Stell career at Oxford and was about to
enter
politics he is quote no longer a Jew as
he converted to
Unitarianism
Unitarianism which as the narrator makes
clear repeatedly throughout the novel
and remember this is written from a
Catholic a trinitarian
perspective Unitarianism according to
guy Thorn is another form of
Judaism CS Elliot raised as a Unitarian
also believed this of his own
backgrounds and I can develop this in
the question and answer session Schwab
throughout the novel even though he
converted is called the
Jew that is presumably why he quotes
hates Christ and maybe uh unarian
Unitarianism perhaps belittles Christ
but hating Christ Accord according to
the novel and he wants to undermine
faith in Christian Christianity and
reinforce what are called in the novel
The anti-christian influences which
typify the age now lot unlike De Maria's
canes and Corelli's cryptic summaries
and as we've seen uh um these popular
novels could take all kinds of literary
cultural stereotypes of the Jew and and
uh bring them all together Thorn does
exactly this with a vast aray of Semitic
representations in a very short space
they begin with a redir Victorian stage
Jew and Jews with red hair actually up
until uh uh the uh 19th century even the
end of the 19th century was much more
common than uh um having uh the uh um
so-called Jewish NOS so red hair was
very very common linked to the devil of
course moving on chronologically to the
hypnotical controlling eyes of sengali
and concluding with the Sinister Jew
being categorized as a bestial
cold-hearted intellectual a reptile
straw is finally defeated though and
this is the point by S Michael Mano s
Michael Mano and who is the benign
mirror image of Schwab he's known as uh
the stay and pillar of
anglicanism not Unitarianism in the
English church so so Michael mono keeps
the English church going and at the time
that included Catholicism and the
Catholic
religion we're told that Mano is a man
of great natural gifts who is has
imaginable wealth is a Jewish convert to
Christianity and has also entered
political life quite literally a mirror
image of and I'll read the slide uh uh
below here and we can see s Michael Mano
the quote below he's the owner of one of
those colossal Jewish fortunes which few
as they are have such a far-reaching
influence on English life he employed it
in such a way which for a man in his
position was unique unique he presented
a curious spectacle to sociologist and
the World At Large of a Jew by origin
who had become a Christian by conviction
and one of the sincerest sons of the
English church as he understood it in
political life so Michael was a steady
rather than a brilliant Force steady
rather than brilliant um in English
culture you can't be too flashy you
can't be too
showy so the other key thing to note
here is that so Michael is given no
physical description to limit his
uniquely benign pres in contrast to his
malevolent double and the annual Italian
word for Mano means manican in English
he said to become to have a far-reaching
influence in English life but only for
good his political career is steady in
contrast to the overbraided Schwab we
don't like um intellectuals we don't
like people to be overbraided who
remains intellectually detached from the
country which he's meant to serve so
Michael instead combines his quote
Jewish brain and Christian Heart
Christian heart which had we're told
already revolutionized Society nearly
2,000 years ago 2,000 years ago such are
the binaries which structure the novel
one character personifies Christ the
other Antichrist only s Michael has the
so-called colossal Jewish colossal
Jewish fortune and Jewish brain to
defeat Schwab who is known as the most
active of God's enemies in England and
I've just got got half a page to go K's
and Kelli's fiction were also the
subject of popular sermons theatrical
Productions and many many films but in
1903 the daily maale rightly a
sensationalist newspaper then and now
rightly declared Thorn to be the most
talked about novelist in England not
that the novels claim to have generated
a great conspiracy is strictly accurate
the conspiracy in the novel is easily
contained and is ultimately the insane
Folly of a single individual rather than
a group of individuals Thor to be sure
was extravagant in his use of Semitic
discourse even describing an El elderly
Jewish man as a great gray
slug which paved the way for cruder
versions of bestial dehumanized Jews in
the decades following but when it was
dark following trulby is a good deal
more ambivalent than its oneeyed
reception the reader could choose
between the good Jew of liberal virtue
or the bad Jew who needs to be banished
from the national sphere which happens
at the end of the novel such binaries
distinguishing between light and dark
characterize everyday anti-Semitism in a
liberal context and allowed those who
engage in race thinking about Jews to
deny that they were anti-semitic
something that happens to this day the
liberal anti-Semitism or the
anti-Semitism of tolerance as it's been
called
continues to this day and I have written
about it very much in contemporary
terms so to finish uh just a concluding
slide if there's
time uh just very quickly but we can go
over all of this in the question and
answers I'm talking here about uh Mass
produce literature I'm asking the
question was Marshall mcclan right so is
the medium the message I'm saying mass
produced literature mainstreams the
extreme absolutely and is a new medium
but does not have a single message even
bestsellers are complicated
narratives I distinguish between Liberal
bation Liberal
bation uh which uh um is something
that's uh between desirable and
undesirable juice which has very much
become State policy so um I'm saying
this happens uh at an Institutional
level it produces race thinking but is
not the same as illiberal
exclusion
exclusion but both as we saw at the
beginning
coexist I also talk about religious
racial and nationalist discourses all
being intertwined so the linear
narrative here that looks at one at the
time I think is mistaken and finally the
key thing that we must must not do uh is
read uh te logically or uh to back
shadow um to read first world war text
as leading inevitably either to the
protocols or to anti-semitic
hatred and there I
finish um thank you so much yeah thank
you Brian um that was so interesting and
I have a bunch of questions and I ask
people to submit them in the question
and answer period I mean question and
answer function at the bottom of your um
screen we don't have a lot of time but
maybe we'll go like five minutes over um
just to be able to uh talk to you a
little bit um so first I'll take you up
on your um offer to talk a little bit
more about your concept of Semitic
discourse which is is really your I feel
like you know a major contribution that
you've made to understanding this um
idea that that uh a lot of the discourse
around the Jew is racializing but is not
necessarily negative and not necessarily
positive but is sort of in this in
between area can can you talk a little
bit more about what that concept allows
you to to get at yes I um I think
talking about ambivalence or
ambiguity is important and important to
this day and important even on social
media so I think uh quite often people
just simply talk about hatred or
hostility now even going back to
Christianity as I've shown and to the
Christian foundations of anti-judaism uh
that was equally uh bated so Jews who
converted were seen as a good thing Jews
uh as well as being seen as Christ
Killers Antichrist so that bation goes
very much back to the roots of
Christianity and I think very much feeds
into liberal culture uh Western liberal
Democratic culture um obviously once you
get a more authoritarian culture Nazism
fascism stalinism then it's a different
story but I'm talking here about liberal
Western liberal culture and I think the
problem with looking at anti-Semitism
just as a form of hatred is that it
answers its own question that's all
that's ever looked at in social media so
other kinds of images of Jews um and the
good bad discourse is simply ignored
which seems to and I've looked at social
media and the whole of labor party
controversy was about dividing Jews up
into into those that were socialist and
not yeah yeah so I to me it's essential
but for all kinds of reasons is not uh
uh followed through and I can make the
link with gender as well it's a bit like
thinking about gender only in terms of
misogyny and nothing else yeah and
that's something that I've worked on a
little bit too that often that split um
is also a gendered split so especially
in the French context which I've looked
at in the 19th century Jewish women are
idealized sexualized and Jewish men are
demonized and that you know becomes two
sides absolutely because je Jewish women
can convert right that's seen as their
body and their body isn't marked by
jewishness and that exactly and I seen
especially young Jewish women it's Al
agis as well but yes only Mar Carelli um
um can take the desirable Jewish woman
uh socalled and and turn her into
something else yeah I apologize for my
called so my sniffling so um I don't
mind I'm here other question I have is
to what extent um this is a British
story here that you're telling or an
anglo-american one versus you know let's
say the the French or the German case so
is some of this um you know argu
ambiguity particularly English in the
19th century No I don't I really don't
think so and and um
um I think the the I think it's much
more to do with with uh the for form
that the Western Democratic states took
and uh in Germany famously you you know
the ostjuden was was uh uh demonized uh
a culture German Jews weren't and I
think that split in France as well I
mean you know as long as France it's
it's often mapped on to the difference I
mean one of the things that defines the
French case is the mix between the
spartic and the ashkanazi populations
and that the spartic Jews tend to be
idealized in the ashkanazi Jews
demonized yeah absolutely I mean I think
there's all kinds of way ways of doing
this uh there's uh and and it does vary
from National culture to National
culture no question uh and because
France has a much more
ideological uh version of this but even
so I think the key is Western European
um it's different say in Russian
literature yeah um yeah okay maybe last
question um this is all playing out
against um the backdrop of the rise of
the sist movement and that's something
that um I feel like in the hall cane it
it sort of came up a little bit but if
you could just say a little bit more
about how the Zionist movement um you
know uh enters into this this story well
I think uh certainly the Zionist
movement and I talk about this in in in
constructions right at the beginning and
and in other articles I've written quite
a lot on anti-Semitism and
postcolonialism um but also divided Jews
up into good and bad I mean just in a
different way uh so Jews uh were seen as
a good thing if they uh thought that uh
um believes in a form of nationalism
especially from the scientist point of
view Palestinian centered nationalism as
opposed to zango's Jewish
territorialism um but uh and and did
denigrate the diaspora you know her s
famously talked about the ghetto
mentality and uh the diaspora being some
somehow degenerate and and Max nordau of
course was a number two to herel and
wrote a wonderful book on degeneracy so
I think the the the um bation of of Jews
the uh Jewish binaries apply to
sanism also to anti-semites as well so
you could be anti-semitic and think it
was great um after in Daniel J that Jews
would uh leave Europe okay last question
I'm just going to take um uh just the
advantage to go a little bit over time
um and just ask you um are there um
Jewish reviews of these novels like in
the Jewish Chronicle for example are
there reviews like what were Jews how
were Jews reacting did Zang himself like
respond um to something yeah Zang did
and Zang was in the audience when hul
Kane spoke at the mbans uh the Jewish
Chronicle reviewed hulc and all uh um
and they were quite sensitive towards
straightforwardly anti-semitic works so
Mar Kelli and and others but but didn't
pick up on the subtleties and didn't
pick up on the fact that hul Kane also
divided Jews up into desirable and
undesirable in his so-called uh Noble
philosemitic novels as well so didn't
pick up on that uh anything that wasn't
simply based on hatred we seen as a good
thing is a good thing right okay we'll
take what we can get so okay um on that
note I want to say thank you very much
for a really um enriching uh afternoon
thank you to everyone who came and to
encourage everyone I'm sure you're on
our mailing list and that's how you
found us today but if you're not please
get on our mailing list and next week
next Wednesday at 5 so not at 4 we have
Ken Stern I'm going to be in
conversation with him about the our
current moment anti-Semitism after
October 7th so thank you again to Brian
it was great to see you on Zoom I'm
sorry we can't have dinner but another
time so thank you very much absolutely
thank you thank you by
everybody